[Applaudissements]
après toi millet la tête à un souci là
vous le dites vous quand quelqu'un
mauvaise haleine avec black m si
quelqu'un voit là il pue de la gueule
est ce que vous lui dites france je le
connais bien je serais moi vous me
diriez oui bien sûr je vais venir vous
voir à l'affairé je peux te dire un
secret à tanger en fait la journée on
attendait d'en faire plus non parce que
je pourrais parler de l'à propos de ton
album très loin
voilà je vais tenir j'adore j'adore je
suis chez moi merci j'adore kirikou non
mais ça va tu peux de la nuit merci
alors c'est toujours gênant ça toi je te
lis jamais dit quand on habite ensemble
mais parfois le matin me rabats là c'est
parce qu'on dormait tête bêche
[Applaudissements]